so witty yes okay wait we from original
notes on the Charlotte didn't even out
here
seventeen half years 17 and we got you
out here my ex old man beat me up well I
had a six week old baby that you had a
six week old baby to die
good boy how long he came out six weeks
very job
Oh first off we're on the last time two
weeks that's our barrier I caught my
best friend and my husband and our B it
makes no schooling higher and I lost my
mind yeah I just burned my baby our baby
and this is tiny the painting picture
the life of my child don't can I thought
be worth it
Saint shitenai from me they want to cut
me
yeah said this if I can't have you
nobody I swear it's fine with me
get out you wouldn't hurt her Pope get
out my face
how ain't watch this let's get out leave
me alone
he's a stalker he likes the stock so I
friend of mine told me California as a
nice place to start over so the battered
women shelters down there got in
touching man place down here and they
bought me a bus ticket go down there
well I get here gray and lose my life
everything all this nice I had
like unless I call the police department
they'll take you know alcohol please
nice and this were to bring on Skid Row
said just bring me you've been here ever
since
tyreq chocolate fondant mom I'd rather
to raise me grandma - she doubted loudly
she died when I was eight father came
back into the picture
and yeah he was abusive
my brother passed away my father beating
for a whole month
tell me I killed her it's my fault it
was my father's my fault so that's like
y'all don't believe in stuff I get like
run off with my world she was my only
thing I had in this whole world
take care of a protecting me to love me
kill me but she got I love her can't
cancer that's my habit yeah what kind of
cancer I have some the cancer that's why
I'm dying
no that's my all you have six months
left
you also have AIDS hey Zuri yeah
what
this is what are you doing here but the
whole time yeah oh it's always appeared
I won't you know the old on you know
that I came to the hospital none
so after your grandmother passed away
you stayed with your mom okay
and he was old uses him right Junior oh
it was so terrible
he said belt buckle wasn't beaten in the
face on
Oh all these yarns just from my father
well some from here but
he slammed my he shot me in the ass but
goes just to see if it felt good
I say mark I sent his second mole back
my ass isn't asking how to feel
the problem is sick
a mirror at one time was a bomb with you
as a child consider moving
when she added through
if I ever swing me that partners all the
solar this [ __ ] won't go baby my [ __ ]
man three half-brothers
what do you mean your view of the world
must be affected by what you've been
through
and now we are still going to how do you
do the world is a horrible place or do
you see hope where do you see a stiopa
now you know is six months ago we saw
him inside though I got a little kitten
on the way and I can't wait no no no
honey honey no girls I'm saying pretty
little girl see that like this movie
nicely okay I'll need I got it right
there we do for money you get I get your
cure
I get that in nine days thanks perfect
time or date or isolate some eight days
since long but when did make you be
talking to me
thank you Mark